foreign
[Music]
thank you
hey everyone from myself and everybody
here at Bethesda we are so excited to
finally tell you when Starfield is
coming out this year
you know we have poured ourselves into
this game and even I'm surprised how
much we can pour it is large uh we're
playing the game all the time shout out
over here to lead producer Tim lamb old
school fans you may remember him from
the Oblivion making of video where he's
sitting on a similar sofa to being
similar things but also uh this June
we're going to bring you into the studio
and give you a deep dive in the game at
our Starfield direct there's so much
that we still have to show you the game
has many of the Hallmarks that you'd
expect from us but it's also a very
unique experience and again thank you
all for all your excitement about the
game your support your comments we
really do read it all and look we know
you've waited a long time to play
something new from us believe it or not
we're kind of the same we miss it and we
really just can't wait for you all to
play it
so thanks and we'll see you soon
foreign
[Music]